[Music]
in don't smoke news yeah yeah he doesn't
he definitely done it every day he
definitely shouldn't smoke at least at
least not in this case submitted by
submitted by Jimmy Hoffa is a smoker 61
succumbed to her injuries after an
oxygen tank exploded while she was
smoking that's well first of all I
shouldn't be smoking by yea tank cuz
they're in your Lambo yeah so that we're
no they're very they're very flame yeah
no isn't what's the word as what they
use it you're still Flambeau it's like
I'm finally flammable amiable there's
two words no flammable I'm against also
another term indestructible there's also
another term that that's that people
confuse oh I guess it isn't thankful
yeah it isn't final easily set on fly it
easily set on fire huh do you don't know
a minute anyway
people get confused all the time this is
probably what happened would that be non
flammable I don't know I'm flammable or
that's not level in flammable it means
it's still 4 mi amour i N how about
indestructible you can look it up later
I went your own time at mad as I went
[ __ ] anyway so yeah Belinda coal wool
died - an explosion in NASH County at 8
a.m. Tuesday morning Oh
her husband was asleep in the other room
when he heard an explosion and she was
being administered oxygen and I guess
she was smoking too and it exploded
because as we all know oxygen especially
pure oxygen like that I think very
explosive very pleasant why all the time
people were like why do we have to take
these useless classes in high school so
you [ __ ] don't do this [ __ ] yeah so
fortunately she died Belinda rest in
peace with their families she died the
way she lived Jesus liked her hair
yeah I guess this is something that
happens you know pretty frequently says
the media reports covering 311 separate
fires involving home oxygen over 20 a
month over 20-month period resulting in
164 deaths 71 serious injuries and a 119
minor injuries this amounts to one death
every four days which is kind of crazy
when you think about it yeah on top of
it too it's just like you're getting
oxygen because your lungs can't
physically take in the oxygen of the
smoking yeah I guess it makes sense cuz
one leads you needing the other and so
it's not like the obviously they get to
the what do you mean yes it does make
sense it makes sense because it's like
yeah this is their smoking they're gonna
be the ones that need the oxygen tank so
those two are gonna be a collaboration a
lot yeah yeah one and then switch to the
other job they're like I'm gonna die or
I get one those cool boys back at the
age where she doesn't really give a [ __ ]
anymore
yeah I'm gonna have my smoke this is the
only reason I still talk to you you're
coming she better do that has I had a
voice box I was walking with my cousin
in our neighborhood and we noticed I had
like a hole right here and if we were
just like what happened like why do you
have a hole in there and then like he
got out his little I don't know what's
called yeah the box and he put it right
there and then he was like oh I don't
remember what she was doing but we were
all fascinated by like he's speaking to
us like do the box of like yoga kill it
as a modern-day rapper
not to make fun of anyone who's like or
anyone my kid my kid my dogs like oh my
god his voice is stored in that box on
Little Mermaid moment I just sounds like
oh because I heard his voice come out
that box like his voice was taken into
their box
hey Siri it's called now he brought food
and this is crew News's [ __ ] best Bob
did I mean yeah so it's pretty
unfortunate that I mean like yeah she's
so addicted to like nicotine and stuff
that she has to continue your downfall
in two different ways yeah for reals
yeah yeah yeah it's unfortunate but it's
like come on yeah but I mean that's I
mean that's something to say like how
addictive nicotine is where you really
see someone every day smoke I'm like
come on yeah come on you people
definitely the most addictive thing I've
ever tried mm-hmm so I just know that
whenever I meet people I always think of
very like clean slate
whereas like oh yeah you know they don't
really drink they don't like smoke
cigarettes but then when I see those
smoke cigarettes I'm like I just get
really sad because I look you're home
ooh I feel the same way but it's also
like they're all they're adults do if
they're over 18 I can make their own
choices
their own choices are this thing for my
own personal feelings and opinions
alright I can look that because I care
about the person I want to die young
yeah there's a difference between a guy
smoking a cigarette and then a guy
smoking a cigarette next to oxygen okay
I got chain-smoking a whole pack yeah
that slippery slope though that's like
causing continued you know and this nose
like smoking seems to be coming cool and
movies again yeah yeah it's we're going
through the Evan flow or it's like sonmi
not cool anymore and then that's getting
kind of cool I think vaping kind of up
to that 200 you gonna have smoke and it
doesn't necessarily have to be from
cigarettes and stuff yeah could be we
but now it now because also vaping is
the non cool form of smoking so now that
boosts smoking back Center you talk to
like I feel like a lot of people thought
baby was like hella cool no no I mean I
mean like old heads and stuff like that
and like people were people who are
already smoking [ __ ] you guys I'm the og
all terms like alright you there smoke
cigarettes or you smoke weed
so like weed is considered the cool kind
of smoke so knows we're doing only two
options in life before e cigarettes are
a thing you're like oh I have to smoke
some no but if you're smoking one of the
two like if you're smoking something
it's either wanted well hopefully it's
either [ __ ] it at the let me cry because
like it brings in the resurgence II
kinda like how how like with the lecture
car is when electric cars are getting
pushed a lot more suddenly I've got what
those people are called the people that
outfit their trucks and somebody that to
dump extra oh you you've seen the videos
where like they'll put their face in
front of the exhaust and pure black
smoke is coming out you'd be like look
you guys this is clean that's a diesel
thing that's a that's a sit they modify
their trucks to push out way more
smoking that needs to just do let me
like yeah [ __ ] you Prius I've seen
videos where they'll find a priest yeah
and they'll drive in front of it and
they'll know gas it and it covers the
Prius impacts in public why it's just a
counter thing it's a counter at for you
I'm cooler than you thing and so that's
why I feel like it's the same thing
we're saying now that smoke smoking is
cool again because now we have a lane
form of smoking for something
interesting we have weed smoking so yeah
because I don't say I feel like because
that because vaping made it okay to
smoke again and like because like we
we've has always been kind of thing
where it's like all right it's okay
unless you're like an old head and then
you're like okay it's not okay even
though old heads all smoked it but um
but no it's like well like vaping is 1%
that like all right if you're you're
there on board you're like you're a
loser
it's like those hipsters you know they
are always super counterculture I mean I
bet when smoking was super big back in
the [ __ ] like 40s and 50s right I bet
the hipsters of that time we're like no
we're clean one of the few people and
then you know back in like what the two
early two-thousands and hipsters were
like during that time they were like the
smokers because that was like the the
weird thing everyone's like oh I don't
smoke I don't smoke and they're like but
yeah I smoked [ __ ] I don't care
anyway kind of thing you know what I
wonder if it's also just because like a
lot of the more popular stuff coming out
it's stuff that set in like an earlier
time period because you have like mine
hunter you have you're talking about all
like the nostalgia I made in the 70s
because they say all right cool yeah
everybody's chain-smoking back then so
that's where we'd see it more because it
changes what a modern day things think I
know it goes back in that time period is
a period piece and it's like yeah you
can't like look at that period of time
and be like oh yeah everyone knew
smoking was bad it's just like no it was
kind of like what that time period was
but we should know better by now
yeah it should be you can tell me a guy
in a trench coat with a [ __ ] yeah
raining in New York is not cool that is
cool yeah it's pretty [ __ ] cool but
what if he was vaping what if it's in
the year 3000 and he's like half cyborg
they're kind of cool days vaping any
guy's voice boxes like that half cyborg
body and he still needs to get the voice
box a smoke ring maybe that's how Blade
Runner came about is like it is like
baby became cool and like that's why
everything was smoked out everybody
everybody's really just like might
slowing clouds all over the place
maybe took over instead of like
cigarettes completely phased out just
babe snappy but the whole time you watch
all that steampunk you thought it was
steam from all their mechanical devices
imagining some dude in like you know
like the the bellows of something that
like usually you're like shoveling and
cold whatever different really it's just
- dude just like pressing buns of the
when he became like a legitimately
national lighter like worldwide holiday
so everybody just hotbox in their house
and release it at the same time later
that's not dissipating hi Fox the house
hot-boxed the world really that's just
la though especially during the summer
months when it's muggy because of the
cars like smoke grenades instead be like
weed your names and like well you know
what everybody a government eaves to
calm down they like open to every
governability i hear that prior to even
when we before weed was legalized that
up in santa cruz UC santa cruz they have
this park now on 4/20 a whole bunch of
kids for years in a row and experienced
this park that you firsthand yeah so on
campus there's this thing called Porter
Porter College which is one of the
college I don't know if you guys and
your college was split up
no but I know about that it's weird yeah
this giant metal area and I'm 420 every
like thousands of people gathered there
just smoke you see cops they're
ambulances there there's thousands of
people are not gonna arrest everybody
and straight up like it's you you're
walkin you see this billow of smoke
it's like above everything and you could
get you could like my friends got second
heights secondhand high just walking
through it I went to the 4/20 festival
in Vancouver and that [ __ ] was like
right at 4:20 on the stage they just lit
up and you just sees giant puff of smoke
erupted from the holy [ __ ] I imagine
it's like you know DJ's they they blow
off all that like the nitrogen or carbon
dioxide or whatever those cannons just
read this goes into the crowd
interesting at the festival cuz
everything was medicated and there's
like one or two boots that's that
non-medicated food and those guys are
making a killing I don't want to die
holy imagine being like so [ __ ] high
that you like think your dad you have
the munchies and then go and get like
more edibles on top of that that just
sounds yeah that sounds so scary oh man
I really got over in Long Beach Long
Beach me and gentrify like crazy of last
year's but like dad doing this change
every time I go back it's crazy it's
nuts I drove you through her
neighborhood and you're like yeah it's
like in like that's all and like not
only that like of all things for their
like because first of all along these
were injured by like crazy like I knew
all the signs but then this was like the
epitome of like gentrification where
they made a mega Whole Foods that
blocked the view of the sea and blocked
the Sun all the boats and some right
there
it's a giant Whole Foods now so
literally like when the sun's out there
you can't see the Sun anymore and you
can't see the sea good morning whole
pretty big building but it doesn't block
out like it's like the Costco like like
high roof it's simply Whole Foods well
like yeah but you know I've never been
there Costco and been like they block
the sunset with this one Nelson you've
got to see doesn't like I'm inside all
right it's Emery Pacifica oh really
yeah yeah
[Music]